نعم اهلا بك يا فاطمه بالفعل يعني استمرار
لتدفق الحافلات على هذا المعبر منذ اكثر
من يومين هناك يعني اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
الى خمسه الاف لا توجد حتى الان احصائيات
رسميه للكثير من المواطنين هذه النسب
اغلبها من المصريين وايضا من السودانيين
والكثير من الجليات التي لفت نظري بان
اغلبها ينتمون الى دول اوروبيه مثل جورجيا
واوكرانيا والذي كان فيه استقبالهم ممثلون
ومبعوثون وايضا بعض السفراء الذين اشرفوا
على عمليه نقلهم واستقبالهم من هذا المنفذ
فيما يتعلق
بال من سجلنا معهم يعني اغلبهم يبدو عليهم
علامات الارهاق تحدثوا باقتضاض شديد جدا
حول هول ما راوه في السودان الرحله
الطويله يعني 900 كيلومتر من من كانوا في
الخرطوم للوصول الى هذا المنفذ ومن ثم
ايضا الارهاق المتوقع للوصول الى اكبر
مركز هنا في بعد هذا المنفذ في مدينه
اسوان بعد حوالي خمس ساعات من المرور سواء
كانت سيارات او حافلات اغلب من تحدثنا
معهم من ابناء السودان اعلنوا بانهم
سيتوجهون مبدئيا الى اسوان هذه المدينه
التي تشهد جاليه سودانيه كبيره هناك
الكثير من الاقارب والاصدقاء الذين
سيتوجهون اليهم ربما لمراقبه ورصد تطورات
المشهد السياسي والميداني والامن في
السودان قبل اتخاذ القرار سواء المكوث هنا
لفتره او التوجه للقاهره او العوده مره
اخرى لان كثير ممن تحدثنا معهم اكدوا
بانهم جاءوا بما عليهم من ملابس هربا من
سيل الدماء المتدفق في السودان خلال
الايام الماضيه بالفعل كانت علامات الرعب
واضحه كانت علامات الارهاق واضحه كانت
علامات السعاده واضحه للوصول اخيرا الى
المنفذ المصري والانتقال فيما يتعلق في
المشهد داخل المعبر هناك ربما عمل ايضا
على قدم وسواق من كثير من الاجهزه المصريه
لاستقبال هؤلاء المتدفقين من سواء من
السودانيين او المصريين او الجليات
الاجنبيه هناك تسهيلات تسهيلات طبيه يقوم
بها الكثير من الاطباء المتواجدين داخل
هذا من مركز بنعبر مركز اغاثه وغيره ولكن
هناك ايضا عمليه تدقيق امني مشدده في
موازاه هذه التسهيلات خصوصا مع من يعتبرون
اطفال او كبار السن او من يبدو عليهم اي
نوع من الاصابه او الارهاق هناك ايضا
تدقيق امني فيما يتعلق بالقادمين تتذكرين
بانه عقب الاطاحه بحكم الاخوان عام 2013
كان هناك رصد للكثير من العناصر الاخوانيه
التي حاولت الهروب من مصر في اتجاه
السودان عبر المعابر البريه ومن ثم هناك
خشيه بانه قد تكون هناك استغلال للفوض
الجاريه هناك ومساله عوده اللاجئين
والتسلل مره اخرى الى الاراضي المصريه
وبالتالي هناك الكثير